[Music]
nick josh congratulations you guys are
in the third and final round of this
competition now when you came here you
faced really tough challenges that
escalated throughout the first two
rounds now we're sending you back to
your home forges to recreate this
iconic weapon from history
the sun medaille
holy this thing is huge
today i gotta try and figure out forging
on this blade i've never made anything
as big as this before so it'll be a
unique challenge this is what i'm
starting with big old piece 5160.
my forge only has about 18 inches it'll
just be working on it a little bit at a
time
try and keep it simple and get something
drawn out to size
this thing is gonna be gigantic
damn
we got the length it's a good start
end of day one i got the whole blade
forged out to a real rough shape plan
for tomorrow is to get to the quench by
the end of the day
yesterday i was able to get the blade
shape to where i want it now i can get
busy grinding and hopefully by the end
of the day to get it quenched this is
going to be a day filled with attention
to detail this is the most
nerve-wracking part it's kind of the
make or break moment
so get it in the oil perfect i pull it
out
i didn't get a curve on it
i need it to have a curve on it because
that will allow it to function the way
it needs to
i've got to stick it back in the fire
and i've got to get it quenched this is
not what i wanted to have happen so here
we go again quench number two
it didn't break
best off there's a little bit of a curve
in it
day two was an adventure pretty happy
with where i'm sitting right now so what
i'm hoping to have done tomorrow is get
the guard fitted up and be ready for the
final day of fit and finish
morning of day two goal for today is to
get everything he treated
[Music]
doing about everything i can to try and
get it as even as possible but here we
go
coming out of the quench is going to be
a real challenge so i clamp it down in
some two by fours the idea here is to
help try and keep it uh
as straight as i can while it cools
end of day two have a quench blade so
far
so good
i'm uh doing okay a little tired coffee
and hate that's what i'm fueled by just
kidding just coffee this morning
the sword looks phenomenal now i can
really start focusing on the fit and
finish so i'm going to start working on
my guard
after a lot of file work i get the guard
fit right up to the shoulders it looks
perfect
now it's time to start securing
everything
that seam there i'll fill with a piece
of cord and then that's going to be
wrapped back to 12 inches
i've got to finish the handle but i'm
comfortable that i can get this blade
done tomorrow goals for today are get
the blade cleaned up and ground and then
move to working on the handle
got the bevel
ground in now i'm gonna start working on
getting this handle fit up
i'm gonna i'll glue these two pieces
together do some sculpting i'm actually
gonna make a little bit smaller than i
would because i plan on doing a wrap
i have a little bit of time left so
start working on shaping the guard
do a little fit on the guard
i'm happy with the shape overall
tomorrow's going to be final assembly
glue up all that fun stuff
yeah i'm just glad will hasn't shown up
so far i'm glad there's no more
parameters i got plenty of them yeah
that'll work
maidsmiths welcome the keel test
well your zamadows aren't pocket knives
they definitely look very long but what
kind of lethal damage can they do to
find that out i will take your weapons
deliver some slashes and killing blows
on this boar carcass
take your purse you ready for this yes
sir
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
all right let's talk about your weapon
here
now the design you have i was expecting
a little bit more of a curve because of
a straighter blade it feels more like
i'm chopping before i'm drawing but as
you can see
it will kill thank you
all right josh your turns are you ready
let's do it
[Music]
all right josh let's talk about your
blade here the balance is good and as
much as i can feel the power in there i
can wield this weapon
and develop some speed and power and the
curvature that you have here does
exactly what this kind of design is
meant to do
every cut was very deep on this carcass
enough to where it cut all the way
through and more importantly
you'll keel
thank you all right gentlemen welcome to
the strength test now to test the
strength and overall construction of
your blades i'll be chopping into the
pots and this horse skull now remember
gentlemen this is not about what your
blades do to the targets this is about
what those targets are going to do to
your blades
nick you're up are you ready yes sir
[Applause]
[Music]
all right nick so
there's not really any chipping or
rolling that i can feel it's just sort
of
just lost its its fine edge yes sir
most of these weapons have
a bit more of a curve and and this it's
got about as slight a curve as i could
call a curve yes sir it's a very very
flexible blade but it did well
so nice and done thank you sir
all right josh
let's do it
[Music]
so josh very well crafted blade which i
like the guard the dimensions the size
and shape of the handle all really
beautiful
unfortunately though we've got
some rolling on the edge of this blade
you hear that
yes so you put an incredibly fine edge
on this and it showed in the kill test
but uh
not so good for hitting pots
it's a great feeling weapon but yeah it
did take that edge damage all right
bladesmith now it's time to find out how
sharp your blades are this is the
sharpest test the dual sandman slice now
unlike the strength test this is all
about what the edge of your blade does
to these sandman
nick your purse ready for this yes sir
all right next talk about your blade
here as you can see it cut the arms cut
the legs disembowel the rice off the
torso overall sir
it will cut thank you sir
all right josh your turn so you ready
let's do it
[Music]
wow
[Music]
all right josh
this is a cutter just the design of it
really lends itself to really draw cut
the cuts are very deep and they're very
clean when you're cutting through the
rolling it took did not affect its
cutting ability so overall sir
it will cut
thank you
bladesmiths the judge's deliberation is
complete they've made their final
decision the new forged and fire
champion is
josh congratulations
nick your blade didn't make the cut doug
markite is going to tell you why
nick the zamandal was designed to be a
horse slayer chopper the amount of flex
you have on your blade and the lack of
curvature made it perform less than that
of your competitor
all right nick
at this time please leave the forge come
on forward my friend
i may not be the fortune fire champion
but by no means do i consider myself a
loser
congratulations
the sword that i made is something that
i am extremely proud of and when it came
down to the decision today just wasn't
my day
[Music]
congratulations josh you were the forge
and fire champion and that's the title
that comes with the check for ten
thousand dollars that one for shake our
heads i'm the forge of fire champion and
i don't even know what to think right
now
it's something that i can show my kids
that if you put your mind to something
100
you can really accomplish something
you